can you not make a video about trump for  like one week just one week  what's the point of the challenge  just to see if you can do it just to see  if you cannot talk about trump for a  week  and what would that what would that  prove  i don't know i mean if you look at your  channel every single day it's like trump  investigation or january 6 committee  it's like why don't you just do one week  where it's like i'm not going to talk  about trump i'm going to restrain from  trump's stuff and i'm gonna go to other  things okay and and if i do that then  then what would we prove or achieve  uh like the whole politics world is  gonna like change everything's gonna  change just based on my youtube channel  yeah wow that's really some i should  think i didn't i that's that's a lot of  power i mean when you think about it  that way that's really a lot of power  yeah i i  i gotta say i sincerely regret uh you've  been one of the last questions  um but thank you